WILL CLEAR.
IN THE NEUTRAL ZONE IS MARCHAND
TAKES IT OUT OF ERTIME WINNER,
ESPECIALLY IN GAME SEVEN.
>> Mike: SMITH GETS A SHOT
SVECHNIKOV TAKES A HIT AT THE
SIDE OF THE NET NOVEL TAKES
ALIVE  AND BACK TO SVECHNIKOV.
FOR JARVIS AND HIS THE
HURRICANES OF THE CROWD GETS
INTO IT., PUCK IS TO
FREDERICK SLAPPED THE SHOT AND
HE IS GIVEN A BIG HIT AND A A O
HAD TO THE BENCH. AWAY, 13:08 L
OF GAME SEVEN.   POST
A POST WITH A HUGE PASS.
AND A TRIP FOR CLIFTON.
A SHOT OF THE BOARDS AND ANTTI
RAANINNING DRIVE THERE.
HEAD COACH IS DOING A WERS THRO
MARCHAND TRYING TO GET A SHOT,
PUT ON  AND THEY SCORE!  TEUVO
WILL FINISH IT  AND
SWAYMAN WITH HIS BEST OTHER
SIDE.
A SHOT AND  FOR
SHOT HIT THE POST.
TROCHECK RINGSGS
AND BERGERON
FINDS DEBRUSK OUT FRONT  AND  T
SIDE CORNER.CKEY GAME.
>> Shane: HE'S HAD QUICKNESS
AND A STEP WHO ONE TIMED IT
TO THE BACK OF THE
THE HAT TRICK, BUT HE MUST BE
SO IMPRESSED WITH THE SONS WORKK
HAULA. ON WILL SCORE STICK OF P
THIS WAS NOT A DIRECT